foreign
[Laughter]
the way I was inside
no one in the history spoke like that
even Prophet Muhammad when you go to his
Sunnah Allah he speaks completely
different in the way is the Quran
the miracle of the Quran is the style of
the Quran you understand so if Muhammad
was just a normal guy how come he came
with this perfect stylish of the Quran
so eloquent when we had many poets from
the Christian poet from the Jewish
forward the Arab poet Christian and
Jewish but they never spoke the way
Prophet Muhammad came with the Quran
right
foreign
challenge
he knows the liar he knows for example
if I make up something in a claim body
with me I'm lying I will not challenge
the people because I know I'll be
exposed but maybe
he challenged people to bring something
like it
and you know why it's funny there's a
guy he's a Christian in Egypt to charge
each other challenge he was making a
mistake in a drama even a child today a
primary school
is challenging everyone he turned out of
paper
and they couldn't remember the other
figures
so what they did instead of accepting
the challenge what they did there was
the war against him
but they were able to accept a challenge
and to expose him that way he came with
his alive so so why is it not extended
not accept the challenge and they had to
choose the war instead of accepting the
challenge
of the writing that that something I'm
not sure how much stress there is in
saying that because
[Music]
yeah
yes yes
two questions
firstly you know anyone in history
it is subjective it challenge people to
make something like it even the Arabs
who are inequate in their speech they
know these humans each there is
wrong then why the Arabs you Christian
Arabs they are accepting the challenge
why they can say Noah they're subjective
anywhere because they know it's innocent
and Allah exposed a Christian Arabs they
are very weak in Arabic language I don't
see how eloquent being eloquent like
results a relationship with God no not
before resolved firstly
right so if I come to a people they will
known to be elephants in their speech
then I bring something and I said to
look this this one the miracle that
foreign
doesn't want to put no one between him
and his servants in worship directly
Pizza
yes because
step by step because when I use our
sunrise
my question to you she said both of them
they are one yes the father my question
so when the Romans were beaten up Jesus
that was fought getting beat up
foreign
imagination the divine nature of God
and that human body
again okay so any Divine thing he did
was because of the divine nature
attached
part of God was divine Jesus was divine
if he was a full man and God was
attached to him no no don't ask me that
Jesus when he was alive which part of
Jesus was divine with God
yes
you said that is Jesus so when Jesus
human being is his flesh is born or the
sword inside him is God
I DNA God God was attached to his human
so they became two inches attached in
one nature so to Nature was inside him
which part of
each Jesus fully Divine okay his hand is
divine his speech will divine his
knowledge how did he get people to arise
from them huh how can he make people
arise
even the Bible Jesus I can't do nothing
by myself
simply
nature
I would say that you have to I would ask
you something else
the point is that Jesus was Holy Spirit
Divine because they are all one this one
they are one there's one point the other
one so so Jesus
he's 100 man and flesh and that that
happened out of his love for us in terms
of knowledge the G's have good knowledge
Divine knowledge
holy God so he was divine
hour yes that knowledge desires both
knowledge or him is knowledge he knew it
but he didn't want to clarify
if you read Acts
foreign
only the father knows the hour
he's Jesus and he said nor the son only
the father
now Jesus
Jesus clarifies what God wants us to
know and God doesn't want us through the
hours
who is he referring to God because they
are one no okay so the sun is good now
I'm talking about when he said Jesus
even the sun doesn't know the hour he's
talking about this doesn't know yeah so
she doesn't know the hours only the
father
so
first of all the main concept
I understand he has two Natures by
nature and human nature doesn't make any
sense but who's going to allow you okay
one nation it is
one nature
the basic points
with the mentality that you're going to
just dismiss
and now so you're dismissing the fact
that God and Jesus
I can't dismiss it by sound reasoning I
don't have to be a Muslim no I don't
have to be a Muslim to know that doesn't
make any sense because by by default if
you say someone is brought you are
negating human being you say it's human
being my people is not God
would you say that Jesus
and we say please and the father are one
I will tell you what is the context of
you Christians what is the context of
that when you say I am the father are
one what is the context
what is the context of that
question okay Jesus said I am the father
are one yeah so either we can understand
or they are one in purpose yes how can
we know if it's me it means one in
essence or one in Purpose By looking the
context looking to what Jesus said yes
because Jesus said to his disciple just
as I and the father are one you are one
with us it doesn't mean they are God
you get me so that doesn't mean they are
good if they are if the disciples are
one with Jesus
that's what another Concepts
bring some Stones Jesus because he
claimed to be God so they choose
that Jesus was speaking about being one
Essence with the father okay so your
food
otherwise the context read it
okay he said why you want to spawn me is
it because the good work I have done so
listen to the concepts under the context
but you don't know huh
you call the Jewish people but you
forgot what Jesus answer quit so what
are you doing instead of fool with Jesus
you are taking the speech of Jewish
people yes Jesus said to them what you
want to spawn me for even because of the
good work I have that they said no
because you claim to be God or one with
God he said is it origin in your law
Christians
person that we have a good day
invites us
to partake in history
of Christ so we have Christ within us
teaching or actual Jesus argument so
this is what makes this important to
understand now it's bringing the third
part of I'm an actual food the holy
spirit that is
inside you yes because inside you okay
and you are a copy okay if I bring a
Catholic now he's gonna say the holy
spirit inside him but both of you don't
agree with each other and both of you
will tell me the holy spirit is speaking
on your behalf so which holy spirit is
lying your Holy Spirit
can I say something at this point
I feel like
the perspective that you are
saying something against like anything
that we have to say you are trying to
produce business
logical options
is
everything
foreign
good night
of course she feels like we're
comfortable when there's seven cameras
no one's asked for anything
relationships
now this place is a bit different yeah
yeah
which is completely fine no problem
like
sorry
now what is this place is a bit
different it's known for debate and
discussion so if you kind of enter upon
it it's like you accepting the fact that
you will be by way of consent films
[Music]
understand
for you guys and it's completely fine
but God has to be someone that you can
Define who has run everything
good for you guys has to be someone that
you can Define all his parameters
elaborate more because when we say to us
ask me when he said well we said
something right now about you doesn't
make sense and then that and then you
said to the cameras okay so you know
things about that you have to listen
what are we talking about here we're
talking about God that we should all of
us we know about you foreign
[Music]
foreign
you agree he does whatever he wishes
according to his wisdom
okay okay
that's what I'm saying that's what I'm
saying that's what I'm saying
it's about wisdom so my question is yes
and what good is what good to eat does
not change meaning it doesn't look up
against his nature because it's
illogical tell me something happy new
code is perfect all the time but at the
same time
okay
so when Jesus became a baby kind of baby
and it was in need of his mother take
care of him he's at the same God who is
self-sufficient
the word of God
thank you
just being like a man no no no no no no
no because the word of God is not the
anger of God God has attribute to work
for friends
let us know if we if we're doing if we
speak all over you yeah my point here is
that when you're talking about this yeah
yeah the word of God
is an attribute of God
[Music]
the things they use these words
if you chase it back within the
philosopher it was 300 years before
Jesus you use the words to describe the
god of University I'm sorry that God
which is one in uh Unity with universe
so they believe the whole everything is
good they read the word logos
if I take him to the hospital now and
I'll show him a baby in nine months old
and I said you know what this baby is
gone you tell me you must be smoking
something yeah because it's beyond our
comprehension and getting back to the
point so it's beyond our comprehension
what does that mean it's not the truth
if someone said because the moment
you're defining
you think
[Laughter]
we're not coming with an aggressive uh
agenda by the way there's no like debate
that we're trying to win or anything
again
what I'm speaking about is something
called Universal knowledge what is
universal news
it's not by necessity for example if
someone said to me yeah common sense for
us our Demons of course we are here you
will never be able to come
if someone said I believe in God that he
doesn't know nothing what do you think
who lives that God knows nothing yeah
okay what do you think if you're right
or wrong
said he said I believe in God because I
believe he doesn't know nothing you
believe he's the true God or a possible
his God or is he talking about my mind
he doesn't know nothing yes okay I don't
know what God he's talking about no you
think why is it about God even if he's
the true God to you or to any human
being you think with the sound isn't it
that God he believes in which he just
told you he doesn't know nothing is he
true God or false god it's complicated
because you're I understand no no
because you're saying you're saying all
right breaking down
does not know anything okay is that a
true God the God he believes in
simple Muslims if someone says I believe
in God he doesn't know nothing he's a
true God of course God
because he knows if he says how do you
know because you know by Nature God
knows everything
the reason we're careful about that
question is we don't believe
did
[Music]
Jesus
because you're talking about the God you
believe is different than Michael yeah
what is the word that you think
about each other because Jesus
that's right that's right you know the
same page he just told me no simple
no we're not on the same page
so my point is
don't be right yeah
I know everything and he says
[Music]
I'm gonna go read my Bible I mean if you
know
[Music]
example
one of them what's your point because
German word
yeah
what is the name of God
that is
for what you know
foreign
is
check it out she's always agree it's
known before that so Jesus
Jesus when he was praying for hope when
Jesus was praying for help you know
before they crucify him he was asking
for Hope yeah he was a friend to himself
who respect someone else again
this is a very nuanced argument and it
talks about the whole reason because uh
Jesus came down on earth right
we're talking about a larger discussion
of our Salvation right there were many
people in the Bible who came prophets
all of them came over word of God but
unfortunately all of them were valuable
all of them failed at one point okay for
our Salvation that had to be someone who
came down invaluable in nature it was
who would be able to take sins of the
world
no but this is what I'm saying my answer
to my answer to is going to be a very
complicated answer me
when Jesus's praying support it was
praying for Hope yeah right was he
prayed to himself or someone else and my
that's what I'm saying right you're
looking at it
and the divine nature of Jesus Is Our
Father
and you know that the chicken it's full
of chicken again
asses
yes God exists Independence
never use this word
as well that's not a human terms
okay okay okay
no no it's not him apart no no no
wait no problem okay
you have a hand yes do you have a hand
yes and the door has a hand yet yes are
they said Johanna
no no no no no no no no no no no no yes
Majesty okay so my point here is you
talking about to go back simple when
Jesus was praying to the father who's
the friend to himself with someone else
but there is
the shepherd the man that works in the
shop shopkeeper the man that has PhD in
Oxford University can understand the
concept of God in Islamic teaching
because Allah is not the god of the
philosophers Allah is the god of
everyone so when Allah send the prophets
and Messengers he send them with a
message everyone can understand when it
comes to Christianity sorry I will come
to you in a patient okay when you come
to Christianity the god of Christianity
literally you have to struggle
understand it absolutely
not everything no no that's what I'm
saying when we're talking about your
brother because he came late we're
talking about the things that we know
about God you and I we know God he has a
perfect knowledge correct so if someone
said to me I believe in God has a
perfect knowledge but on the other hand
he said to us you know worship I believe
God has a perfect nourish but I believe
postal code doesn't know my name
that's what
thank you very much
knowledge and Jesus doesn't know the
hour okay when he said no one knows
except the father and you agree the
father he's not Jesus yes when he said
only the father even though only he says
no one knows the day and the hour not
even the angels in the Heaven nor the
son but only the father even the Holy
Spirit Doesn't Know It And The Voice
very interesting why is very interesting
Allah
they ask about day of judgments the
meaning of it Allah said no one knows
except Allah Jesus they said the same
thing
foreign
the Bible says that
yeah
sin so when the woman from Panama
do you think it's okay to call someone a
dog because
yes because her daughter she was
possessed by Jinn all right and she was
following him and beg him for help yes
she was begging for help correct Jesus
the old love me who was ignoring her do
you know who told him just help her it's
not Jesus out of love eating to help her
no no no no or coach the Bible narrative
his disciples they were sent to him just
help other people should keep following
us just help huh you could just follow
with us you're not telling me the full
story
I haven't finished it
okay no no I'm gonna speak to him
you'll have respect
no no the artist is a different thing
now
they
care for them then they begged him to
help us
compare that when a woman
Jesus
he said to her I have only been sent to
the Lost House of ship of Israel
and he says not befitting to through the
campus of the bread to the dog yes
even the dog would eat the crumble of
the his master so he said because of
your belief she been healed yeah so why
did he resemble the colonized woman a
dog yeah no I do I give you stuff and
give you cake
[Music]
right now foreign
Disciples of everyone else
he is
different things
[Music]
he ceases to be good if you're able to
Define him sorry it's okay
all right
but for the right of the Bible
they were philosophers because that's
why they tell them
that's why even the Christians you
cannot extend as Trinity you struggle
that's what I said you cannot explain it
that's why Christianity is dying in the
western world that's because why the
Christians of the 21st century they
think you know it doesn't make any sense
God become a baby
we have a live chat that is because
Christianity my friend we've responded
okay okay no problem no problem okay no
problem
I can me and you would do
experimentation
for me five years been dead fill them
close
in East London
is
dying
the Young The Young consume our time
no but when you say something which
isn't true we have to adjective
okay
come come I need to speak to you bye-bye
what's your name